The Blade of Calling refers to Melina as "the
one who walks alongside flame".
But what happens, if she sits alongside flame?
What happens...if you kill her, at the very
beginning of the game?
With Fire's Deadly Sin and the Bloodflame
glitch, this is possible.
Now don't worry, she doesn't stay dead, and
it doesn't ruin your game..but it does get
us an extremely close look at her extremely
unique death animation.
With her dying breath, Melina casts one last
incantation.
A golden erdtree erupts, and remains a while
- healing you in an AOE from all that burn
damage you took, for a small amount, over
time.
Melina can actually cast this unique incantation
if you summon her for the fight with Morgott,
and she can rarely cast it during the fight
as well - not just when she dies.
Gameplay, and lore-wise as well, this is very
similar to the spell "Blessing of the Erdtree",
which also heals you with the Erdtree's warmth
and grace, over time.
And Melina, who was born at the foot of the
Erdtree, certainly has a good claim to this
powerful manifestation of its power.
Even if she does feel compelled to burn it
all away.
For number two,
In my last video about Miquella, we talked
a lot about his unalloyed gold needles, which
can be used to repel the influence of outer
gods.
Of course, you can give a needle to Millicent,
who inserts it into her body to fight off
the Scarlet Rot of the Rot God..but YOU can
also use the final version of this needle..to
repel the influence of the outer god of frenzy,
and remove the frenzy from your eyes.
But what you might not have known, is that
the original item description for this needle
originally said that "to repel the interference
of the outer god...you should pierce this
needle into your eyes".
I wonder if they changed this detail so that
they wouldn't have to create a specific animation
for it?
Can you imagine?
For number 3, did you know that the winged
design of the Mausoleum Knights is clearly
inspired by the armour of the ​​winged
hussars, who were the Polish cavalry between
1503 and 1702?
u/FaithlessnessLucky55 shared a side-by-side
comparison of the two on Reddit and it’s
incredible to see just how similar their armor
design is.
And it's a grand excuse to talk about why
Elden Ring and Poland decided on such extravagant
designs.
In Elden Ring, the winged ornamentation of
the Mausoleum Knights is intended to evoke
the Deathbird, acting as a "self-inflicted
curse that ties their spirits to the land",
so that they might better serve their masters
in death.
And for the polish cavalry, the rear wings
were intended to demoralize enemies during
their charge, as the hussars were the elite
of Polish cavalry, and not a force you would
want to see charging your way.
They assembled their wings from the feathers
of raptors, birds of prey who also provide
their feathers for the Ravenmount assassins
in Elden Ring, who also evoke the deathbird
and have a chestpiece called the "Raptor's
Black Feathers", which states that it is "a
ritual implement for transforming into a Deathbird,
if only by imitation".
Number 4 is something that I decided not to
include in my video on Elden Ring's cosmic
sorcerers.
And it's that..Radagon shares a very compelling
connection with Raya Lucaria’s Knights of
the Cuckoo, who bear the twinned cuckoo bird
as their coat of arms.
So... a cuckoo is a bird that lays eggs in
foreign nests so that other birds can raise
its children instead.
This is something called "Brood Parasitism,”
which is… well, it’s kind of messed up
when you think about it.
Cuckoo birds even go so far as to push eggs
and other baby birds out of the foreign nest,
so that there's less competition for their
own offspring.
And..Radagon kind of exhibits this cuckoo
behaviour with Rennala.
He uses her to birth three demigod children,
only to eventually leave her with a parting
gift of a giant golden egg, which Rennala
would then treasure, seemingly at the neglect
of all else.
And you could even take this theory further,
and argue that Radagon/Marika might have helped
to establish the Knights of the Cuckoo.
For one, their crest is the twinned cuckoo,
which could represent the twinned body of
Radagon and Marika.
Second, the Cuckoo Surcoat item description
even says that the Cuckoo knows the insignificance
as there is a legendary black moon of Nokstella
talisman that features that signature twin-cuckoo
design.
So you have to decide: Did Radagon/Marika
simply co-opt this ancient icon for their
own purposes?
Or is the cuckoo its own thing, and just coincidentally
similar to the whole situation with Radagon
and Rennala's golden egg?
Whatever the case, you have to admit that
it is a very compelling theory, and offers
a great bit of characterisation for Radagon.
This being, who only really appeared during
the war with Liurnia, as if his sole purpose
was to get cose to Rennala, and undo her from
within.
Another lore topic that I just keep on talking
about are the folk found all throughout Limgrave.
Many of these wear the Guilty Hood which has
a description that reveals that it’s, “The
garb of those accused of lesser crimes, indicated
by the collar of sharpened branches.”.
But back in version 1.0 of the game, the description
read that it was the, “Garb of spurned Tarnished
who were forced into slavery in the Lands
Between.”
It goes on to say, “The Tarnished have been
wandering into the Lands Between from beyond
the Sea of Fog in dribs and drabs since times
of old.
Most are killed on arrival, but the few, unlucky
survivors are taken as slaves.”
I wonder why this was changed?
The 1.0 description seems so much better.
For number 6, there are some interesting details
to find on the Erdtree Sentinels as well.
If you look close enough at them, you’ll
notice that they’re chained to their horses.
u/Groomgrim pointed out on Reddit that if
you have a look at their waist, you can see
how an ornate chain wraps from around the
Sentinel, down, and around the horse.
This helps to explain why, from a gameplay
point of view, they can't be dismounted like
other larger enemies on horseback, such as
the Night's Cavalry.
They’re truly a ride and die pair, and a
difficult one at that.
One aspect of Elden Ring that isn’t talked
about very often is the game’s Hardness
stat.
This dictates whether or not a weapon will
bounce off an enemy when wielded with one
hand.
Fextralife has a helpful list explaining these
tiers, if you want to learn more.
But did you know..that there's one enemy in
the game, that absolutely no weapon can match?
All hail the crystal crab of Raya Lucaria.
Not even the coded sword, the cipher pata,
or a whips, are a match for the hardness of
its shell.
Another lesser-known mechanic is called "Overkill",
and it's something that you can use to massively
boost the amount of runes you receive in-game.
So this has been around in the Souls series
for a while, but basically, if your first
hit on an enemy does damage that exceeds 150%
of their maximum HP, then you will receive
20% more runes as a result.
In general, this helps the rewards for fighting
to scale with the strength of your character
a bit..but where tihs overkill really comes
in handy, is when you're engaging in rune
farming.
20% more runes is a LOT when it comes to something
like farming the albinaurics at Mohgwyn palace,
so if you're currently not making use of this,
consider ways to make your character just
a little more powerful, and hit that threshold.
For number 9 - everyone knows about the Dectus
Medallion at this point, for having two halves
of it allows for easy access to the Altus
Plateau..
But did you know that's not all it does?
If you have this in your inventory, it also
prevents the two guardian golems at the top,
from attacking you.
For number 10,
Have you ever wondered why certain enemies
drop Bell Bearings?
Like, what even is a bell bearing?
It's a term that, as far as I can tell, doesn't
actually exist in the real world.
When I first read it though, I thought it
said "Ball-bearing", which are little steel
balls that go inside of an enclosure to serve
a purpose, like rolling to reduce friction,
or to apply ink from a pen.
So if I had to guess, a bell bearing might
be the little ball that goes inside a ball
bell enclosure, so that it might function
as a "clapper" and give a bell its ring.
This would make sense, as we do give these
bell bearings to the Twin Maiden husks, who
are finger maidens that hold staffs that are
full of such ball bells.
But why do we do this?
Well, bells in the Elden Ring universe are
a tool that can be used to summon, or call
to spirits.
The best example of this is the spirit-calling
bell that the player uses, but this mechanic
exists in other From Software games as well,
like the Bell-Ringing Women in Bloodborne,
who also rings for spirits to fight on their
behalf.
So when the twin maiden husks receive an NPCs
bell bearing, we [Special thanks to Quelaag
for suggesting this theory] speculate that
this enables us to interact with their spirit,
to learn additional spells from them, or receive
their items, as if they were still alive.
After all, many bell bearings seem to hold
the essence of perished NPCs.
They even might have been borne or held by
these NPCs, as many appear to have a fingerprint
design upon them.
So after thinking about it, the word "bell
bearing" is quite an impressively loaded phrase
for these little items.
It suggests that it's a part of a bell, that
it's been borne by an NPC, and that it provides
a bearing, pointing one towards their spirit.
Props to the translation or writing team,
for this one.
So recently, twitter user Diddykolo shared
this video.
It seems like this statue in the shaded castle
watches you whenever you have your back turned,
only to turn away when you get closer.
It's..extremely creepy - until you figure
out what's actually going on here.
So after going to investigate, I realised
that this is actually being caused by textures
loading in, depending on how close your character
is to them.
When getting closer, it simply loads the assets
that make it look like it's looking towards
you.
That's not to say this isn't creepy as hell
- I remember something similar happening to
me with the inanimate doll in the Hunter's
Dream of Bloodborne, and it scared the absolute
hell out of me.
One thing I've always wondered about is the
sequence of events that leads to you ending
up in the stranded graveyard, at the beginning
of the game.
Remember when you were defeated by the grafted
scion, and heard this?
It's as if you're dragged..then thrown through
the air, only to be submerged underwater..and
then nothing, until you finally awaken in
the Stranded Graveyard.
Now what I always assumed this meant, was
that the Grafted Scion drags you, then throws
you off the cliff, into the ocean below.
Then, eventually, your body might wash up
towards this beach at a sort of high tide,
as this beach does have a cave that leads
straight into the stranded graveyard, where
Melina eventually finds you.
But another theory was recently proposed by
ShieldScuff, in a youtube short that reveals
that the stranded graveyard is actually right
below this crevasse in Limgrave.
Falling into this crevasse usually kills you,
but if you fly the camera down there, you
do arrive pretty much directly where your
character awakens.
So as the theory goes, our character, and
the many piled coffins nearby, might have
been hurled down here, in years passed.
There's even a bunch of crucified bodies near
the hole that lends credence to this theory.
The counter argument, however, is that there
isn't really a hole in the roof of the Stranded
Graveyard that lines up with this crevasse.
I mean..there is a tiny hole..but that's not
very convincing.
There are a few caves like this with clear
holes that don't line up with the outer geography,
and I think this is such a huge missed opportunity
by From Software.
I reckon it would be a great little experience
to fall off a cliff only to survive, and be
halfway into a dungeon.
So for a long time, amongst the high-level
PvP community, people were noticing instances
where they would block an attack, and perfectly
poise through it as well, without taking any
knockback.
Now, in PvP, and PvE, this sort of technique
could be extremely useful, because it enables
the player to take no damage AND poise through
an attack in order to deliver a punish, or
even a backstab.
The only problem was that it wasn't known
how to replicate this seemingly random event.
Or at least, it wasn't, until now...
Thanks to a discovery by discord user "CMG",
and thanks to videos showcasing it by Steelovsky
and JeeNiNe, we now know that to replicate
this "irregular poise event", as it's been
called, what you have to do is be sprinting,
and take your finger off the sprint button,
and on to the block button, in the exact frame
where you would usually take damage.
This performs the perfect block with poise,
and allows you to deliver the punishing blow.
I've always craved some sort of Sekiro-style
parry system in Elden Ring, so I was really
excited to learn about this.
It's difficult to perform, for sure, but it
really heightens the skill ceiling of the
game, and that's usually a good thing.
It must be hard to be a game developer and
learn about things like this - do you remove
the unintended effect, or do you embrace games
having this random buggy complexity to them?
Speaking of the developers, I think we should
give the animators some credit.
Like..yes, they've reused a lot of animations
from previous games..but that's not being
lazy, that's just being efficient.
Because they clearly ton of effort into animating
so many other things instead.
For example, have you considered that almost
every single enemy has a specific animation
for falling, and remaining asleep?
I know this isn't really a secret, I but I
feel like it still bears mentioning.
Every animal, so many enemies, and bosses..all
of them have sleep effects, even if it's extremely
unlikely that most players will even inflict
sleep upon them.
And I bring this up, because in the recent
Miquella lore video, we talked about how there
used to be a mechanic where enemies could
be found sleeping out in the world, requiring
you to harvest their dream mist.
So if we ever do get Miquella or St. Trina
DLC...man, it would be so smart to make it
so that enemies and animals could be randomly
found sleeping around the world, so that these
animations could be put to use.
Speaking of sleep - have you ever looked up
during your fight with Rennala, to see where
the scholars are respawning from?
Turns out, they're all falling out of these
hanging cribs.
We've talked before about how these beings
are rebirthed through Rennala's Great Rune
of the Unborn, within "Rennala's umbra", or
shadow, so
to speak.